mail
[Musique]
l'antenne dans une minute
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente la nouvelle
émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
en fait voir c'est quoi le truc là dans
la main là c'est un peu c'est à cause du
non mais attends moi j'en sais rien vécu
d'aussi l'habitude de regarder ces trucs
là en crypté mais pourquoi ils fouillent
le net la peau mais ses clés thierry ces
partis saluent cette double je dis
rituel antennes wimax pour jouer avec
nous ce soir la superstar billet on le
croyait au fond du trou il nous revient
en pleine forme aurait sonné de tous ses
succès l'immortel claude françois
superstar du nez on le croyait au fond
du trou il nous revient en pleine forme
auréolé tous ses succès ni morte un peu
de françois reinhardt ces gars là ça
marche très bien bien du monde il ya
beaucoup de monde s'est passé où ces
derniers temps ces derniers temps je
travaille plutôt sur la côte à côte
d'azur et les chansons préférées des
gens c'est quoi l'idée dernière
évidemment les magnolias alexandrie et
puis dansante
1 tu changes est vraiment une ampoule
quant à lui dans l'accident non c'est
pas une ampoule
ouais c'est une apathique et 10 km là au
cas où ces paradis ça marche les galas
très très bien
j'ai passé où ces derniers temps le
dernier gareth est en suisse à deux et
en général les chansons préférées des
gens c'est quoi les titres les plus
connus les derniers titres rio bangui at
my way alexandrie mais aussi le vagabond
chansons populaires sont françaises
changer vraiment une ampoule quant à lui
est en excellent une applique des
crevettes là-haut déjà oui quelques unes
sont venus nous rejoindre
merci première femme invitée dans double
jeu la fin qu'est de tchao pantin a
troqué ses épingles à nourrice contre la
winchester de calamity jane et elle va
faire un carton
agnès soral
[Musique]
bon alors on a tout mon plat matters et
y est c'est bon
marie-élaine deveault voire à nier sera
le bon jour
ça vous fait quoi de voir ici ça me fait
bizarre
ma pauvre ten sacrée tronche à volonté
jantes et je veux pas me mêler mais
d'intérêt faire sympa dans l'avion en
dehors de vos talents de reproduction
qu'est ce que vous trouvez le plus sexy
en vous ça dépend enfin chacun ses goûts
de moins sexy tout est extrêmement sexy
chez moi et contrôler c'est très chaud
et torride
comment ok ce qu'a dit non un mistral ça
me fera gagner du temps dites moi ce qui
est négatif à votre sujet on peut se
tutoyer peut-être grande gueule mais
sympa qu'aimerais tu changes est en toi
or je me fais plus d'illusion m'a dit
que c'était pas possible
est ce que tu es une vraie route
mais si on va passer les pumas non je
continue contre elle vient comment as-tu
pleurer pour la dernière fois hier soir
sur scène hier bien fait mais j'étais
payé pour quelle insulte qui t'a fait le
plus mal 1
c'est grâce à fait tellement tout le
temps mal que as une fois on m'a dit un
agent j'ai été voir donc je ne citerai
pas votre nom c'est aux frais de la pub
en plus je me dis que j'avais aucun
intérêt qu'ils pensaient pas vaincu ce
duel fera jamais rien ça m'a fait un peu
mal alors que je fais très bien la
vaisselle tu te fais draguer vous est de
l'américaine vous êtes de la pelouse oui
parce que moi j'aime bien les gars ont
dû manger comment après c'est pour
prendre des notes et bien ses classiques
genre robin ma fille vous racontera à
quoi reconnait tue la passion naissante
sorte de feu l'intérieur un seul coup ça
se voit comme le nez au milieu de la
figure
je me tiens si facilement mal et 6 mai
qui compte c'est une dernière le savoir
pas qu'il est court mais qui me plaît je
crois qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
pourquoi tu as couché non pour remercier
ceux qui à thionville le plus d'épater
mais les gens qui m'ont trahi j'ai envie
d épater est atterrante
enfin c'était une commande a obligé
est-ce que tu regardes les jeux
télévisés pas tellement je suis pas la
prochaine fois je vais faire la vie des
bêtes ou un truc comme ça un truc plus
intéressant je viens moi j'ai bien
quelque chose intellectuelle exclusive
moi tout de même enfin à vous les
studios
or bien que le cadre on arrête de
regarder dix ans
d'accord ça va faire comme vous savez
qu'ils vont ressembler à danièle gilbert
madail
audi no depuis qu'elle s'est retirée la
frange en line renaud j'adore ce que
fait ça marche avec fabien ont très bien
fait ma poulette ça pas mal alors on va
pas refaire tout toute la carrière tchao
pantin coluche les 10 films le théâtre
duras dorin la facture mais quand même
un truc qui est drôle c'est qu'il paraît
que c'est toi qui a fait changer de
coiffure à serge la main voyez pourquoi
tu veux tu as une place de coiffeur
c'est pas mal c'est très réussi sur les
mieux qu'avant ouais t'as pas du départ
moi je suis bien à la maison tu avais
une mèche norway ouais ça ne les deux
vont bien ça te plaît mieux
impressionner son front dis-moi chaud le
théâtre samedi soir je t'ai vu au
théâtre montparnasse dans calais midi
s'il a été battue m'a pas vu un moment
je te fais un petit si je devais être
concentrée à la fin ouais à la fin nous
rappelle je sais pas si tu m'as vu
c'était moi c'était très très bien j'ai
beaucoup aimé
au début on est un peu comme ça c'est
drôle c'est rigolo
et puis après petit à petit on se laisse
prendre dans l'histoire enfin c'est une
scène très émouvante vers la fin et
j'étais ému c'est quand on chante et
fait moins chien afin que début juin
pas du tout j'ai beaucoup aimé et j'ai
trouvé ça très très bien c'est
l'histoire de calamity jane ont en
commun de tableau jeudi sept tableaux et
c'est ça si jacques chronique effet la
mise en scène et a beaucoup de décors
beaucoup de personnages sans grosses
productions comme en voit peu dans le
privé c'est généralement le théâtre
privé non subventionné font plutôt des
pièces à deux quatre personnages là il
ya en tout 40 45 personnages donc 25
personnages importants
il ya dix sept comédiens donc le jeu de
savoir qui fait plusieurs rôles ça fait
drôle tu es en actions tellement beau on
ne voit même pas les changements
dominique borg a fait le décor les
costumes on nous a fait les décors et
jean-noël fenwick a écrit la pierre jean
noël panneaux et qui avait fait les
palmes de monsieur schulz équitable a
duré deux ans à paris dont elle peut
partir à peu près pour deux ans qui a eu
quatre molières
je souhaite autant de succès que les
pales de monsieur shoot alors c'est une
pièce c'est une épopée c'est l'histoire
de calamity jane au far west
calamity jane sin
une femme qui a aidé à la construction
du phare oise beaucoup de femmes qui
t'oblige un peu de se mettre en pantalon
et c'est l aventure c'était tous des
faits l'équipe 1 des comme ça en
caravanes et des cris marche ou crève
et puis ensuite on a essayé toutes ces
femmes de les faire rentrer dans le rang
pour qu'elles élèvent les enfants il ya
quelques femmes qui ont eu du mal à le
faire d'abord elle en l'occurrence était
sale elle avait l'habitude de faire des
métiers d'hommes puisque effectivement
elle a été éclaireur elle a été
chercheur d'or elle a construit des
chemins de fer elle a été coursier pour
la poignée voilà enfin elle a fait
énormément de travail c'est un
personnage qui est à la fois drôle et
très très émouvant parce que entier donc
justement il ya connaître picard est
comme ça qui est l'histoire à travers le
far west où ses tableaux très dumas
finalement et puis à côté un peu absurde
à la beckett parce que elle passe son
temps à travailler pour une fille que
finalement elle ne connaîtra jamais ou
très peu je viens la boîte deux fois
dans sa vie bah oui c'est difficile
d'être une femme libre au far west à
l'époque n'avait pas eu de deux
féministes et avait pas de crèche et
elle était seule elle a été la femme de
wild bill hickok et
il a laissé sans pension alimentaire
donc comme elle savait faire que des
métiers d'hommes en bon balle a confié
sa fille à quelqu'un c'est une pièce qui
est touchante mais qui n'est pas que
dramatique on rit on pleure et c'est là
la france de journal fenix et qxc à la
fois et des gens qui mouche et il ya des
gens qui poussent ça arrive fait beau je
vais avoir à me lire avec ça je sais me
porte à la presse et du sel est ce que
tu es concerné par l'écologie à fond
c'est comme si tu me disais est ce que
ça te fait ça ne dérange pas qu'on
marche qu'on donne des coups de talons
aiguilles sur la tête de ta main avait
fait savoir tu sais ce que c'est l'effet
de serre oui enfin c'est quoi eh bien
c'est la pollution qui nous qui nous
recouvre qui réchauffe qui réchauffe la
terre ici là de tout le nord font et
bien on est ensevelie sous les eaux
voilà nous sommes sortis de l'eau avant
c'était la guerre du feu me n'en citer
qu'un
vous n'êtes pas un sujet tu as bien
c'est de l'info si l'intox à ces de
l'écologie
l'effet de serre vous connaissez
certains gaz peu lors laissent passer
les rayons du soleil mais empêche la
chaleur de s'évacuer vers la haute
atmosphère
résultat la terre se réchauffe
principaux responsables gaz carbonique
et les chlorofluorocarbones mais il y en
a un bien moins connu le méthane exhalé
par les bovins ou plus simplement leurs
hôtes vache c'est tout le problème de la
digestion le l'herbe par les ruminants
cette digestion est faite par des
fermentations qui elle-même dégage du
méthane en quantité importante
les fouaces à sa façon c'est un atout
que ce soit la fête
d'ailleurs si le tube est bouché il
arrive même à éclater par notre option
quelconque une pomme ou un truc comme ça
il arrive ça les fait éclater selon une
étude américaine les éruptions de bovins
seraient responsables de 15 % des rejets
de méthane et chacun sait que le méthane
est moins présent dans la basse
atmosphère que le gaz carbonique mais il
est soixante trois fois plus polluant un
goût 20 contribuerez au temps à l'effet
de serre que les deux tiers de toutes
les pollutions que nous rejetons en
utilisant de l'énergie fossile
c'est à dire les combustibles et les
carburants n'empêche que il ya toujours
eu des animaux sur la terre et je pense
que la terre apportera des animaux
encore longtemps comme ça qui va laisser
polluer
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si c'est pas encore un procédé pour
essayer d'imposer sur les vaches une
taxe anti pollution
oui est-ce qu'on pourrait pas essayer de
mettre aux vaches un masque à gaz qui
neutraliserait le gaz qui ne pourraient
pas l'atmosphère et le pet de vache me
direz vous eh bien rassurez-vous le pet
de vache lui n'est pas polluant bon
alors est de la prouesse de l'intox
agnès à l'oreille alors pour vous
laisser le temps de jouer chez vous de
bien vous engueuler en famille ou entre
amis et de taper sur le minitel voilà
bon maintenant il tape sur le minitel
c'est nouveau ça vient de sortir
en attendant d'en écouter wives and fall
of the decade
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire
tu
mais faire ça
mais dans cette voie
[Musique]
et
c'est tout
[Musique]
et
jma
[Musique]
bien sûr
je
[Musique]
non
tu
monsieur
[Musique]
en attendant soir cela alors tu sais que
dans double je reçois des grosses stars
confirmées style david bowie dave
stewart ou et lewis lloyd cole nous on a
aussi à coeur gilberte hypoxie plus de
ça a aussi à coeur de trouver des gens
qui seront au top 50 dans quelques
semaines quelques mois ou quelques
années et on pense qu'en ce qui concerne
ton groupe c s'est vendu ya pas de
problème
alors pourquoi reprendre melody nelson
comme les niassènes pense que c'était
une chanson qui nous apparaissait une
des plus belles de gainsbourg ou parce
qu'on n'est pas un groupe qui chante en
français on se donnerait est bon quand
l'album est sorti au début décembre ont
certaines personnes nous ont demandé de
chanter en français ou nouveaux
conseillers donc on a essayé de faire
une reprise
et puis voilà donc on a pris cette
chanson là alors en pensant que c'était
une chanson très facile à faire
maintenant est pas facile du tout à fait
que gainsbourg mail une mélodie
complètement différente par rapport à la
musique etc
sa part est évident réaliser quoi mais
bon là pour un nous ce qui se passe
c'est que on l'a fait pour cette
émission l'homme s'est terminée par un
bon c'est vraiment on est vachement
obama voilà non mais vous la faites très
bien mais dis donc t'as pas vraiment un
look de chanteur de rock and roll
comment ça se fait lazio c'est ouais tu
faisais quoi dans la vie avant de faire
une fleur et d'accueil je fais toujours
dans la vie autre chose c'était quoi
informaticiens
alors elle donne un peu de lenteur
l'hérault de vaches sont ils en partie
responsable de l'effet de serre
cloclo à toi de jouer alors je trouve
que c'est de l'intox
tu penses que c'est de l'intox bon ça
peut lui moi je dire moi je dirais que
ça peut lui les ports aussi peu évolué
beaucoup il ya trop de d'élevage
d'animaux et on laisse pas assez reposé
la terre et même les animaux sont au
plus bas par leurs excréments
c'est absolument dégueulasse que sa
colonne
les antibiotiques jury de le pain et
doivent le clos c'est la folle un peuple
moi je pense que c'est plutôt de l'info
de la faux oui tu m'as dit que c'était
moi je dis que c'est d'un taux de ceux
ci un peu exagéré je pense que la guerre
du golfe pollue un tout petit peu plus
dans mon avis les familles au québec tu
penses que c'est plus dur que les
lalalala photo synthèse comment
s'appelle de la mer rouge c'est une cata
personne en parle ça hier on s'est un
petit peu déchiré pour nos quatre bidons
d'huile et de pétrole
tout le monde est content tu me crois
que c'est terminé voilà maintenant on
parle beaucoup de cas rémy jane d'être
enfin tout de même c'est un port des
écouteurs on va savoir si c'est de
l'info ou de l'intox on écoute notre
expert et bien bravo claude désole
claude puisque c'est de l'info
je savais qu'il fallait s'excuser dans
son repaire enfin la bomba savoie alors
fini par un commentaire là dessus
oui diriger un commentaire puisque une
très sérieuse étude américaine qui a
coûté près de deux cent dix mille
dollars je sais c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est déjà ça prouve qu'aujourd'hui
les vaches dégage 15% du méthane présent
dans l'atmosphère
les végétariens eux prétendent avoir
trouvé la solution ne mangeant pas de
viande mais ma chère agnès mon cher
thierry mais cher claude mon public tant
aimé je vous pose une question
croyez-vous qu'un rôle de végétariens ne
dégage pas de méthane dans la halle aux
sports et 2 go 1 en faveur de couples
aux ambitions c'est pas compliqué ça
fait un port cloclo je veux dire même
patrick roy pourrait le faire ça écrit
des bouquins
ça fait un peu plus tôt et voilà
je vois d'où ça va très bien les
papillotes
bon alors on va demander aux gens ce
qu'ils pensaient de toi dans la rue et
c'est pas terrible
c'était mon quartier enfin c'était j'ai
repris du temps à m'en parle alors je
suis triquint puis je suis sorti en
chester on va regarder
oui
comédienne vous intéresse ou pas
pourquoi moi c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment hors circuit nom qui se
maintient un peu comme elle peut mais
bon j'ai pas d'antipathie particulière
pour elle mais vite sympathie
physiquement vous la trouvez comment
moche cette fois un fusil que j'apprécie
beaucoup
elle est plus côté à l'argus et où elle
est allée voir sa prochaine pièce du
tout
[Musique]
exceet physiquement pas du tout loin de
là il a trouvé comment je pense qu'elle
est plus lente ou rapide intuitif alors
j'irai bien à partir du 1er là je peux
pas croire que j'en dise à toi on fait
des mois qu'ils sont bourrés mon avis je
sais pas ya anguille sous roche
as tu crois tu penses que c'est de la
fox je pense que c'est un peu petit mais
chauffe on connaît on va voir alors on
va voir sur qui portait la question et
pensez-vous de line renaud jean reno
monsieur que pensez vous de lire
notamment que pensez-vous de line renaud
forte des toits non plus par les légumes
et ça m'a rassuré quand même non je
passe dans lequel amitié ouais c'est moi
ouais je sais justement alors calamity
jane c'est un garçon manqué c'est dur si
réussie qui vit dans un monde d'hommes
qui s'habille en homme pour avoir la
paix parce que mon avis ça devait être
assez dangereux d'être féminine et pas
pratique
à cette époque d'avant fêtes et dur pour
toi de rentrer dans la peau d'un garçon
manqué je me mets une chaussette
ce qui est difficile c'est vrai que j'ai
un rôle de 2,2 g pas de jeunes garçons
jusqu'à la fin d'après midi
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas la partie qui
m'a été plus difficile c'était jeunes
c'est bizarre de faire le jeune garçon
ça mais c'était dur cet édifice il était
petit il voulait pas être un garçon si
si mais si tu veux je trouve cette
pratique depuis ses deux boucles suite
des aventures et d'autres filles depuis
que qui que calamity tient défie à
nouveau record jamais jamais je suis
vierge moi même au pelage vous qu on
n'avait pas le droit on nous faisait
dormir avec les mains sur la couverture
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert qu'on
pouvait faire des trucs ce dessous
forcément je trouvais ça louche tu
penses pas des gens qui changent de fait
[Musique]
je critiquerai plutôt ce qui ne se
refusent pas de sous mais rapport à la
pollution n'a pu y a pas que les bovins
connaissent pas venir c'est un véritable
problème c'est horrible j'ai connu des
gens qui se faisait opérer comme on dit
à marrakech faire couper les couettes et
elle n'avait pas l'air plus heureux à
l'arrivée
quand ils sont partis et c'est
malheureusement des gens qui se
suicident très jeune on va voir un truc
là dessus justement
le chiffre 1 pour les hommes le chiffre
2 pour les femmes le système des numéros
de la sécurité sociale semblait jusqu'à
leur immuable pourtant une étude est
actuellement en cours sur la création
d'une homo clôture réservée aux
individus changeant de sexe ces derniers
seraient identifiés par le chiffre 3 à
l'origine de cette réflexion
le souci d'une meilleure organisation
mais surtout la volonté d'un contrôle
plus strict des prescriptions un certain
nombre de médecins font des certificats
de complaisance pour dériver certains
traitements hormonaux prévus pour
d'autres applications vers les
transsexuels alors par exemple le
traitement du cancer de la prostate se
traite par des hormones pouvant tout à
fait être utilisé pour les hommes bout
de vouloir devenir des femmes bon je
crois que notre but à la sécurité
sociale et de rationaliser les frais et
de faire le maximum d'économies
une fois leur opération réussie les
transsexuels déposent auprès des
tribunaux une demande de changement
d'état civil afin d'obtenir des papiers
conforme à leur apparence de la réussite
de cette étape dépend le succès d'une
nouvelle vie je suis né avec le numéro 1
maintenant j'ai choisi d'être une femme
donc j'ai été opéré
et donc j'espérais pouvoir bénéficier du
numéro 2 maintenant on m'apprend que
donc je vais avoir un numéro 3 donc pour
moi c'est absolument dramatique parce
que si j'ai le numéro trois sur ma carte
de sécurité sociale
bon ben c'est terminé quoi les gens ne
me considéreront plus jamais comme je
suis c'est à dire comme une femme
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés est actuellement saisie du
dossier
elle peut approuver ou rejeter
l'introduction de ce chiffre 3 il amène
une notion de groupe notion qui est
pratique on comprenons tout à fait pour
la sécurité sociale pour les problèmes
d'organisation et prom de contrôler mes
notions qui heurte notre éthique
le numéro de la sécurité sociale est un
laissez passer pour la santé le travail
et l'éducation
la décision de créer un nouveau groupe
est grave c'est donc le ministre de la
santé qui jugera avant la fin de l'année
s'il est opportun ou non de poursuivre
l'idée de la création de ce chiffre 3
voilà le reste de la peau est de l'intox
d'abord à niasse à l'oreille
non mais jusque là les garçons s'est
joué après les autres elles vous
attendent peut venir
alors je suis pas un père et ses terres
hier les choses avant alors vous allez
réfléchir pendant la chanson pour vous
laisser le temps de jouer chez vous de
taper sur minitel jeu plutôt que de
taper sur votre soeur votre frère votre
mari on écoute de marne
[Musique]
mais
tu
m
tél
wendy
mais
pai
je suis
[Musique]
ce faire
pasteur
[Musique]
des souris
op
à cholet
c'est nous
irak ap
monsieur
le
ok
vous
et
atchoum
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
j'aime
m
op
du
moi je te paye
g
b
la justice
l'espace
je suis
m
[Musique]
est ce vrai
et
non non non je pensais qu'en bon il
faisait de la peinture j'ai rien passé
je me dis quand même quelle émission que
françois revient vers moi aussi j'y
reviens papillotes qui naîtra [ __ ] au
four enfin alors le chiffre trois est
étudiée par la sécurité sociale pour les
transsexuels piot clos à toi tu jouais
tu me dis si c'est de l'info ou si c'est
de l'intox mon avis à deux têtes de la
toque et toi tu penses que c'est de la
faute c'est de l'intox
moi je pense que c'est de l'intox
j'avais dit que c'est d'un oeuf
mais je sais pas on va écouter on va
savoir c'est la poussée de l'intox
philips est à toi philippe guérin bravo
claude vous fait des progrès au fil de
cette émission devenue de plus en plus
mûr face aux sujets que nous vous
présentons puisque c'est de l'intox
rapport
[Applaudissements]
également il ya une autre solution c'est
le petit médaillon avec le formol fait
l'autre solution alors le score et le
combien le score ça fait 2 1 pour cloclo
tout à l'heure je dis zaki et même
patrick roy pouvait le faire il a
téléphoné ils veulent faire garder tout
ça fait chier quand même fini puisque
pas un commentaire à faire sur le
résultat de cette épreuve le 3 pour les
transsexuels ce serait vraiment plutôt
sordide
à ce propos nous avons eu un mal fou à
trouver un vrai transsexuels parce
qu'aucun transsexuels arrivée rihanna
qu'il n'avait pas subi ces trucs dans
monabanq
il n'aura jamais une voie commune sera
bon je suis désolé moi qui me prend plus
dans vos depuis quelques accents moi je
dire voilà quoi
applaudissements bref que tu croises
extra terrestres y en a parmi nous oui
il ya des transsexuels et des exploités
est-ce que tu croises extraterrestres et
bien
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas pas sous
la forme soucoupe volante machin mais je
pense que c'est d'être prétentieux que
penser qu'il n'y a que là
une forme humaine
je ne trime et sicav et tish et si tu
avais des preuves de l'existence des
extraterrestres
je veux voir les points je veux
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un champ de blé perdu
au milieu de la campagne anglaise
un champ où depuis plus de dix ans
quelqu'un ou quelque chose des signes de
superbes formes géométriques
c'est l'histoire de la presse la presse
qui cultivent les histoires les
histoires d'extraterrestres qui font des
ronds dans les champs de blé et à
l'occasion qui font vendre aussi du
papier c'est enfin l'histoire 2000
hypothèses pour trouver la raison de
cette histoire mini tornade en grès mal
dosé militaire mal entraînés divinité
nous délivrant un message et surtout la
crème des explications scientifiques est
donc incompréhensible
le vortex plasmatique toute l'angleterre
le monde entier même en parle et
cherchent pendant ce temps les
spécialistes joue dans le jardin pendant
dix ans personne ne les dérangera de
peur que les extraterrestres ne se
refuse à atterrir troublé par ce trop
plein d'agitation et puis des
scientifiques qui attendent l'arrivée
des soucoupes volantes c'est beaucoup
plus un pack des inventeurs de bombes à
neutrons
mais voilà un beau jour de l'été dernier
deux papys futé sont allés proposé
sûrement même vendre leurs scoops à la
presse anglaise ces deux retraités
peintres du dimanche dessinent eux-mêmes
ces pistes d'atterrissage pour petits
hommes verts
armé d'un bâton et d'une ficelle il
avait bluffé le monde entier et même les
japonais pourtant duras baratiner nos
deux papys après des années de jardinage
commencé à avoir du mal à expliquer à
leurs femmes
les raisons de leur virée nocturne il
s'était même lassés de leurs bluff
pourtant génial
il souhaitait récolter la célébrité que
devait leur apporter ce champ quand on a
eu assez de faire des cercles et bien
nous avons décidé d'améliorer notre
technique de travail est aujourd'hui
plutôt réussi et certains scientifiques
très fiers annoncèrent sans rire avoir
enfin trouvé la solution du mystère
on doit voir tout de suite que c'est un
canular
j'ai fait n'importe que mort il ya
aucune symétrie
c'est vraiment un bruit évident mon cher
watson
pas si évident pour certains
scientifiques ingrat qui trouvèrent à
redire persuadé que ce simple trucages
étaient trop gros pour tenir pendant dix
ans mais trêve de bain
verne et de racontars nous à double jeu
nous connaissons la vérité
la voici en exclusivité ce sont bien nos
deux papys qui ont dessiné ces ronds
mais c'est certain ce ne sont pas des
humains
la preuve regardez bien cette photo de
l'un des deux vous ne remarquez rien
aller chercher cette antenne fixé à sa
casquette
eh oui cet homme est bien un
extraterrestre
ce que je n'allais pas dire c'est pas du
tout la même chose un bout mais ces
deux-là faut absolument c'est que de
l'info tu la connais c'est évident est
ce que tu es au courant de l'histoire tu
sais de la polémique au sujet de
l'indemnisation des gens du spectacle
ah oui je l'aï vendre sa réforme en
jeane manson nathalie baye jane birkin
me reidar qui touchait le chômage était
au courant pour peut pourquoi pas avec
tout ce qu'on donne
ouais moi je sais quand j'étais enceinte
qu'on n'a pas voulu de moi pour
travailler bain avec la sécurité sociale
me donnait pas du tout les 90 fonction
d'un salaire normal alors que je
travaille depuis des années des années
j'aurais bien aimé comme donne au moins
du chômage
moi je suis d'accord pour travailler je
sais que maintenant charasse a décidé de
retenir à 60% à la source de tous les
salaires des artistes ou sa pratique
moi je préfère savoir ce que j'ai dans
ma poche et moins de dépenses et je
serais d'accord moi je préférerais qu'on
nous comprenne l'impôt à la source et
calimity jane ça peut rapporter pas mal
de blé quand même mais ça dépend si vous
venez donc c'est pas vrai ça c'est de
l'intox mais je vois que tu y crois quoi
que les gens sont prêts de mettre ça
finalement
ouais je crois que ce qui est plus
pratique puisque les artistes sont pas
des bons gestionnaires et qu'ils ont du
mal à gérer leur fric pourquoi pas leur
prendre la voilà à quoi la soupe c'est
réglé alors à l'époque où tu faisais la
queue comme ça où l'unedic oui la fedic
on parlait toujours des transsexuels
l époque on faisait la queue aux assedic
à l'unedic tu n'aurais pas aimé qui est
des gens qui fassent la queue à ta place
est bien
j'avais trouvé la combine avant ouais il
m'est arrivé de dire voyez une camarade
ah bon bah on va s'gêner nommé au
maintenant et pas que les sociétés qui
font ça on va regarder certains la télé
dans la télé une des maladies les plus
pernicieuses de nos sociétés dites
modernes une maladie qu aucun pays n'a
encore réussi à guérir c'est la tante
interminables devant les guichets
d'administration nous séduire et pour
les clients
et bien j'ai attendu 14h45 exactement si
quelqu'un attendait à votre place
qu'est-ce que quelle serait votre
réaction
je serai ravi je veux vous dire et bien
que cette jeune femme garde son sourire
une société parisienne vient de mettre
au point pour les gens pressés un
service de poireaux professionnels leur
travail consiste à patienter dans les
innombrables files d'attentes muni de
tous les sens muller indispensable pour
obtenir une carte grise un visa
touristique le remboursement d'une
assurance maladie etc
et c'était un petit à petit à travers
nos service de coursiers livraison
express nous sommes rendu compte que les
gens en avaient assez se déplacer de
perdre des heures files d'attentes dans
les consulats dans l'est dans les
préfectures etc
enfin dans toutes les administrations de
ce chicorée si vous me passez
l'expression avec les avec les gens
derrière les guichets et qu'ils avaient
bien envie dans beaucoup de cas qu'on
fasse ce travail fastidieux à leur place
nous sommes accueillies généralement
assez bien dans la mesure où d'abord les
petits gars qui font ça sont des gens
qui font ça tous les jours qu'ils
finissent par connaître les ficelles qui
savent comment ça se passe
qui font gagner aussi du temps à
l'administration et ça c'est très
important puisqu'ils présentent des
dossiers conformes des choses précises
bien établie tu commences par la chambre
de commerce de paris
là bas j'en ai pour 20 minutes
d'attentes en moyenne le matin à partir
de l'âge parents consulat la libye de
construire libye on a une bonne attente
l'après midi je fais des préfectures de
police
n'importe laquelle
ça peut arriver une heure une heure et
demie d'attentes suivant le monde sinon
suivant la préfecture aussi préfecture
de paris
c'est très long il ya les particuliers
qui arrivent avec des problèmes sur
leurs dossiers et ça ça cause des
problèmes au guichet la personne est
obligée de lui expliquer et ça ralentit
tout là que quoi
tandis que nous quand on passe ça va
être tout est en règle enfin avec nous
il ya aucun problème y aurait que des
coursiers c'est vrai voilà le reste de
la peau est de l'intox d'abord à niasse
à l'oreille alors pour vous laisser le
temps de réfléchir
laisser aux gens le temps de jouer chez
eux il faut que tu appelles militaire on
va écouter
peter en des électrocutions
[Musique]
lorsque je peux pas de plaque taper sur
les pad
j'attrape d'un coup comme ça l'an vilain
13.4 le seul props et claquent comme
appartient monde à chaque fois
l'office top pour un excès de speed
aucoin mme astrid ou bien du parc de la
bigne exact
[Musique]
telindus tant que je coulais full speed
qu'il y avait du smag aliments mais elle
te plaise et pas si con je te doutes
avec laquelle il ya pas de problème
promis juré
[Musique]
k
je prends l is pleased ita dibagnette ce
soir
fillon sur le cloud
je me suis 724
la dynamique et coude à nolan
si tu me prévenir
[Musique]
tha
m
et
ouais ouais ouais
en forme isr bonsoir ça va ouais alors
dans la série nous on passe des stars
mais on découvre aussi des gens qui
commencent donc peter 1,10 electro
kitchen bande alors pris une seule côté
un peu pressée pour la musique et
gainsbourg un peu pour les paroles c'est
un bon mariage non ouais mais c'est les
gens que j'admire et qui m'ont influencé
et donc ça me sens forcément comment
t'as fait pourtant pourtant album dante
débrouiller d'aller le mixer chez prins
à minneapolis aps les portes du studio
et je voulais un ingénieur qui qu'ils
sachent me seconde est entre guillemets
pour faire les instruments quand j
arrive attaquant et qu'ils sachent une
guitare ou non pour toi et donc on a
pensé à mark plati que travailler avec
prince et
on eut envoyé aussi une cassette il a
dit ok on a envoyé une cassette encore
rapide cela et ils ont écouté à bas et
ils sont tous que ça bien très très bien
en italie
pourquoi cette fascination pour les
années 70 mais assez simple mon père mon
père jouait dans aer et
mes parents ça vivait avec des pattes
d'eph des grosses lunettes et démonte
d'écoliers et où j'étais vraiment hyper
influencé quand j'étais petit par part
ça quoi et j'ai des flashs qui me
reviennent et je peux pas m'empêcher
quoi
ouais c'est génétique et voilà c'est
quasi génétique
ouais si ça marche la bon tu fais
d'abord double jeu mais est ce que tu
vas te taper tous les 20h30 ça commence
à marcher dans une enceinte et gagnent
pas tous mais nous on aime bravo
le clos à toi de jouer des poireaux
professionnels payés pour faire la queue
à votre place
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox ce
serait pratique
l'info c'est de l'info ouais toi aussi
tu m'avais que c'est l'info et toi de
l'intox de l'intox
on va écouter notre expert philips est à
toi il ya du relâchement il ya du
relâchement claude par contre claude
c'est beaucoup mieux puisque c'est de
l'info à l'ap le dit alors
éruption le score c'est de 10 mois à
propos de poireaux comment on s'organise
avec les clodettes parce que quatre ça
faire de trop c'est quoi le score ces
deux bords des [ __ ] à patrick roy
patrick kron tu as un commentaire public
oui au départ c'était un sujet intox et
puis en grattant un petit peu on s'est
aperçu que c'était un sujet un faux et
c'est tant mieux parce que moi j'ai
passé un certain nombre d'années à
attendre pour passer à la télé si
quelqu'un veut plus attendre à ma place
ce serait près à propos ma chère agnès
tu es venu me demander pendant la
chanson quel prix
c'est je te rassure tout de suite c'est
pas cher c'est une sorte de barre m
en fait c'est fonction de la taille de
la queue moi je pensais que ma fille
pourrait regarder l'émission
je crois que ça va lui mettre une classe
et de là bas un fait qu'on parle en
tronc dix mois
soit les concernés par l'écologie qui
est une mère de famille qu'est ce que tu
pense qu'on devrait venir en aide aux
parents orphelins aux parents orphelins
à l'eau alors sérieusement qu'on devrait
venir en aide aux parents d'enfants au
parent de reflets pour pour fermer le
jeu c'est une question peu spécial que
vous me demandez là j'ai des difficultés
à répondre oui je suis prête à venir en
aide aux parents orphelins
personnellement vous seriez prête à
faire quoi pour ces gens-là parents
d'orphelins ça dépend ce qui m'est
proposé enfin je veux dire ce qui est
suggéré
il faut agir intelligemment sortie en
boîte à des sorties en boîte
on va l'avoir
les sorties en boîte
les sorties en boîte pourquoi pas
voyez-vous pour eux et aux parents aux
parents d'orphelins mais ces décisions
feu là ils n'ont pas de parents c'est
idiot votre question on attend quoi pour
aider les parents d'orphelins à sortir
du trou à votre avis à l'heure actuelle
je crois que c'est notre gouvernement
qui dépense beaucoup d'argent où il ne
faudrait pas qu'il faudrait de le
dépenser sur ces choses là et non
lorsqu'il fait l'horrible monsieur
seriez vous prêt à venir en aide aux
parents d'orphelins oui parce que je
trouve qu'ils ont besoin de décors
préhension
connaissez vous même des parents
orphelins mais beaucoup ont cours
actuellement
là vous vous posez des choses ce sont
des gens qui sont un peu comme vous au
bout du rouleau et beaucoup l'eau je
suis pas au bout du rouleau
je pense que c'est difficile pour un
orphelin de garder un contact accès par
an soit assez dur quoi seriez vous prête
à venir en aide aux parents d'orphelins
aux parents de refaire oui oui oui vous
feriez quoi pour les aider à sortir du
trou savas par la télé ça un ancien de
la radio
mais quand même ça s'émerveiller moi tu
n'es pas vraiment prête à venir en aide
aux parents encore pas là mais
heureusement des gens qui sont prêts à
le faire dumouchel mais ça nous a si le
corps est encore chaud alors que les
jours en revenir à ta pièce bah tiens un
oui alors qu'elle me jean n'a pas connu
sa mère et c'est sans doute pour ça
qu'elle est incapable de lever sa prix
finalement c'est difficile de donner
l'amour qu'on n'a pas reçu ouais bon
j'essaye de mettre à sa place forcément
puisque je suis sur scène donc j'ai
vraiment essayé de la comprendre et je
pense qu'elle a dû avoir peur que sa
fille soit soit critiqué puisqu'elle n'a
arriverai pas assez fort c'est d'être
quelqu'un d'autre qu'elle même pour les
lever alors pour ma fille et ça va très
bien c'est ma fille ma fille hamoir mais
oui je la donnerai à personne parce que
tu avais un chien non pas le chat ata 2
chats vous recherchez chat probablement
qu'on regarde de plus en plus de
français abandonnent leurs chiens
morosité économique et dont ils ne
peuvent plus assumer les dépenses
qu'entraînent les chiens surtout envie
une étude récente de l'insee nous le
confirme en moyenne et par an pour un
chien les français dépensent légèrement
plus que pour un enfant
une des raisons de ce chiffre est la
diminution du nombre de foyers modestes
possédant un chien et l'augmentation de
ces même nombre dans les classes les
plus aisées
nous remarquons une recrudescence de
personnes abandonnant leurs chiens parce
qu'ils s'aperçoivent que l'animal coup
toulon revient trop cher
nous avons réalisé une étude récemment
c'est-à-dire en mars 91
cette étude dont le nom et le cou du
chien dans le foyer français fait
ressortir des points très significatif
au total 1 foyers dépensent 2500 francs
pour le chien qui se ventilant
différents postes l'alimentation 4500
francs les frais de dressage 500 francs
les frais de toilettage environ 1000
francs et quelques divers
je vous passe les détails donc au total
2500 francs contre à titre de référence
11150 francs pour un enfant en moyenne
bien sûr cette étude a été faite sur un
échantillon de 1000 foyers toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles
confondues
comme leurs maîtres les chiens vivent de
plus en plus dans les agglomérations
urbaines
ils occasionnent par là même l'achat de
toute une gamme de produits canin qui
n'existait pas autrefois et grève de
plus en plus le budget domestique
conserve gastronomique soins corporels
joujou et gadgets divers l'amour qu'ils
veulent manifester pour leur animal quel
qu'il soit est proportionnelle aux
efforts que qu'il veut le faire il faut
absolument l'impossible même plus que
l'impossible vraiment pour mon chien je
ferais n'importe quoi parce qu'elle fait
partie de moi même sur l'enfant soit sur
l'enfant sanofi nous avons des gens qui
font des familles complète et parfaite
où il ya papa maman de deux enfants est
le troisième enfant est un animal puisse
de france à peu près la même chose pour
mon fils que prochain j'aimerais bien
voir comment l habiller son fils alors
la première année les gens en moyenne
dépense plus pour leurs chiens que pour
leur enfant s de l'info s de l'intox
pour vous laisser le temps de jouer chez
vous et pour vous laisser à vous deux le
temps de réfléchir toi tu vas me dire à
l'oreille ouais
eh bien on va écouter nos écoles
[Musique]
des noeuds
m
cela
les presque
jusqu'à 10
jeudi
depuis
chine le sont
[Musique]
et
le maire
m
elle martelé
ouellet
excellent jusqu'à oui
oui
jusqu'à
si les
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
com
c'est plus
oui
j
tu connais
c'est ok
les français dépensent en moyenne plus
pour leur chien pour leurs enfants
est ce de la faute au esse de l'intox
toi tu m'as dit quoi toi de jouer au
clos je crois que malheureusement c'est
de l'info ouais mais toi un peu flou
[Musique]
alors si l'index
tu dis que c'est de l'intox et ben
j'aurais pas voir comment les enfants
serait bon d'avoir écouté un expert fait
libérer va nous le dire tous alors avant
que le tout vous finissez bien asseoir
et désolé coq l'eau vous finissez mal la
soirée puisque c'est de l'intox
correspond bien vers 10 sont aujourd'hui
je suis pas payé pour te balancer le
score mais enfin bon ça fait 3 2 mais ça
fait 3 2 pour quitter pour toujours mais
celui à bravo beaucoup
alors pour toi vive la france les
français sont venus avec leurs enfants
c'est de l'intox encore que si on retire
les allocations familiales la sécu les
congés maternité les places prioritaires
dans le métro tout ça c'est pas pour les
chiens
enfin sérieusement un enfant c'est un
petit peu moins cher qu'un chien c'est
beaucoup plus pratique ça ne discute pas
quand c'est en chaleur un simple seau
d'eau règle le problème
et en plus ça remplace parfaitement le
port d'armes
c'est pas pour rien que les pauvres font
des gosses et que les riches achètent
des chiens quoique si on considère les
allocations familiales et britair dans
le métro et dans plusieurs cas c'est ce
que m'a dit papa doc a dit alain c'est
que j'étais d'accord avec juges tu vas
voir défiler des tu vas voir défiler des
cadeaux sur son téléviseur à tous vas me
dire ce que tu préfères ce que tu
choisis corps
[Musique]
alors devant toi ça marche
le compaq 10 ans machine philips
amplificateur turbo basse plus le
baladeur pour pâques 10 minutes on tape
le vivre un autre locaux
je prends une bêche oui tu crois que tu
es sorti de l'auberge toi ben je sais
pas c'est clair que je viens avec moi
interview qu'on fait immédiatement
professional bull a toujours raconté
[Musique]
agnès est ce que tu t'es déjà confessé
oui beaucoup quand tu étais petit quand
j'étais à part te partir de ma
profession de foi j'ai été élevé par les
soeurs
j'étais au l'institut john cheese
saint-joseph j'ai appris les bonnes
manières
est-ce que tu approuve le divorce
[Musique]
oui oui je trouve ça plutôt bien de se
séparer si on s'entend pas parce que tu
apprends que la contraception
oui
est-ce que tu as couvre la sexualité
hors mariage
qu'est-ce que tu éprouves
l'homosexualité ce qui va est-ce que tu
as prouve l'avortement pas comme méthode
de contraception le bacon recours
détresse oui j'avais les péchés mortels
alors les péchés mortels c'est quoi déjà
j'ai su appliquer à ouides cette
culpabilisation j'ai subi pendant mon
enfance qui consistait à m'envoyer
professional à confesse qu on la nommait
où je me souviens très bien on était
dans l'est dans les couloirs de
devant la chapelle et on se demandait ce
qu'on allait dire et c'est j'ai copié
sur les péchés de deux camarades de
classe et je me souviens que l'on
m'avait demandé de faire quelques je
vous salue marie quelques votre père et
ensuite je me suis dit puisque j'ai payé
pour ses péchés
je vais pouvoir en lego m haies
c'est je ne savais pas du tout où ni
l'esprit à faire ces choses là comme
deux volets 20 centimes dans le
porte-monnaie de ma mère et c'est le
concept du péché qui m'a donné l'idée la
recherche d'autres envisagent donc
chaussé leurs capitaux je les ai connus
tu ne tueras point donc ça c'est dix
commandements alors je sais plus je
confonds tout qu'est-ce que tu pêches
par orgueil
forcément on est obligé d'être d'être
orgueilleux un petit peu par envie celle
envie qui
ce qui nous pousse à à avoir la force
d'obtenir des choses donc c'est pas mal
tout ça pas empêché source à un bonbon
moteur par lui
alors la luxure il ya
et il ya la morale
qui vient s'entrechoquer avec la
l'éducation fera oublier
j'étais très jeune en 68 donc moi j'ai
vécu la libération sexuelle
la pilule donc la luxure
je sais que tu es prête à tout si tu es
ma personne avec qui tu es ça dépend si
cette personne ne mérite ou pas je suis
capable de me soigner de l'amour comme
si on me disait que j'avais la gangrène
je serai capable de mutiler d'un membre
je pense beaucoup de gens disent je si
j'étais handicapé je préfèrerais mourir
en jeu j'ai déjà failli mourir je
préfère être handicapé plutôt que de
mourir et
je préfère vivre sans la personne que
j'aime c'est négatif plutôt que que
négativement avec la personne que j'aime
je crois au bien et au mal mais pas dans
un sens forcément religieux type jeu
j'ai peur de la religion puisque elle
est écrite par les hommes donc elle est
forcément écrites pour mener
une masse pas très intelligente mais je
crois qu'on a besoin de croire en
quelque chose de plus grand que l'homme
puisque l'homme est très prétentieux et
je crois que ça peut s'appeler dieu et
que je crois que c'est bien rendu donc
tu crois que ça peut s'appeler comme ça
qu'est ce que tu as déjà essayé
d'embrasser quelqu'un à travers une
grille de confessionnal non même toi mon
petit chou personne normale
[Musique]
oh
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu